it's almost unheard of for a serving
member of the canadian armed forces to
speak out against government policy
especially like this canadians have been
lulled into believing that the same
government who suppresses your
freedoms in the name of safety will one
day just reward you back with your
freedoms army major stephen schladowski
adopting a popular buzzword of those
protesting covet 19 rules and vaccines
that folks is the very definition of
tyranny
schledowsky says he's served in the
forces for almost 21 years
including in canada's mission to
afghanistan he also says he's
unvaccinated four months after dnd
ordered members to be fully vaxxed along
with other public servants schledowsky
refused a global news request for an
interview
the department of national defense says
it's investigating dnd says these are
difficult and stressful times for our
country and the canadian armed forces is
not immune to these stressors the
department says discipline and being
accountable to duly elected officials
are crucial for military members noting
those who disregard these principles
undermine the very foundation of our
institution
and that anyone who brings discredit to
the forces will be held accountable can
receive in his video schledowsky urges
other military and police members to
oppose covet-related policies
it comes as canadian intelligence
reports indicate far-right extremists
are looking for ways to recruit soldiers
and cops they know when to start uh um
conveying these types of messages within
within the military ranks
to other potentially susceptible
individuals so
it's problematic and it's an incredibly
difficult challenge
another layer of complexity at a time of
widespread unrest
ross lore global news ottawa